Pi stallchasers. They seem to break the
laws of gravity and they're just a cool
looking poi pattern. And by some
miracle, somehow I've never done like a
proper tutorial for them on my channel.
So, I'm going to fix that today.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And today I am finally getting
down to business and teaching you how to
do stallchasers. But before we dive in,
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel. Big thanks
to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests,
Flow Toys, Pyoter Light Toys, and
Ultraoy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible. You can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-B business friend of the channel,
Becca Beckonin. Thank you so much for
supporting my channel, my work, and my
mission. Stallchasers, they look so
cool. They are also challenging in ways
that you might expect in a whole lot of
ways that you are not. in particular. I
love seeing that nice tabletop feel that
happens as I bring them over top and it
takes a little bit of work to get there.
Now, I also love to give people some
context and background for the PO tricks
that I talk about. So, I'm going to talk
a little bit about the origin of
stallchasers here. If you just want to
fast forward to the lesson, the tutorial
on how to do them, you can go ahead and
jump ahead to this time code right here.
Also, just a quick note in terms of
prerequisites here. If you want to get
down your stall chasers, you absolutely
positively need to already know how to
do both your downstalls as well as your
upstalls. There is no ifs, ends, or buts
about this. You have to be super
comfortable with both. And I'll go ahead
and link two tutorials I've done for
both of those tricks down in the
description. All right, so a little bit
of background on stallchasers. Take all
this with a grain of salt, by the way,
cuz most of it is being delivered to me
secondhand. But basically, my
understanding of stallchasers is
something like this. that basically um
stallchasers are a thing because Uda
Imamura had a move that looked something
like this back in the day. And uh Thomas
Johansson of Neasol fame decided to try
and take it into a wall plane kind of
context instead of the wheel plane combo
that Uda was originally doing. And one
of the most legendary PO patterns in all
of Flow Arts history was born. Now, if
memory serves, the first video I ever
saw of a stallchaser would have been a
tech blog done by Swedish PO Spinner
Mirror and I way back in, I want to say
2008 maybe. Uh, it was sandwiched in
amongst a bunch of other patterns. And
so, I didn't think much of it at the
time, but within a couple years, that
one pattern had completely taken over
the poi world. That was the move we all
had to learn. And now it's become so
popular in its own right that there are
countless variations involving things
like body tracers or anti- spins or what
have you. This is one of the most
popular po patterns out there, probably
rivaling caps in ubiquity at this point.
Okay, so the first part of this is going
to involve just learning the pattern
that your hands have to go through in
order to do stallchasers. We're going to
start with our arms spread eagle out to
the sides, shoulder level, pointing
straight out to either side. We do not
want to bend our elbows here. A lot of
people do it. I don't think it looks
very good. Extend your elbows as you're
doing this. Now, I'm going to have you
start with your right hand. Um, not
because I think this pattern has to
start with the right hand, but because
I'm going to give you direction specific
instructions here, and so I had to pick
one. Your right hand is going to swing
down and around past your hips over to
join your left hand over here on the
left side. So both hands are reaching to
the left and now together they're both
going to reach up and over going over to
your right side. All of this is
happening in wall plane. Now your left
hand is going to sweep down and around
past your hips straight out to the left.
So we've returned to a place where our
arms are spread out. Next you're going
to have that left arm reach down and
around. Meet back up with the right
hand. Go up and over. And then your
right hand is going to go down around
and out. This is one rep of the pattern.
So we want to think right goes around,
both goes over top, left comes around,
comes back, both go over top, and the
right goes back. That's the full
pattern. All right. So to get started,
we're just going to have the left hand
poi hanging below our left hand over on
the left side here. And the right hand
po, we're going to be starting from
basically an upstall out over on the
right side. So, as the right hand sweeps
down and around, it's going to meet up
with the left hand, and it's going to
bring both of them up and over together.
The left hand, of course, is going to
swing down and around to stall up on the
left side. And then it's going to drop
down and around, catch the right hand,
and go back out to the left. So, it's an
upstall with the right, comes around,
downstall with the right, up stall with
the left, comes around, downstall with
the left, up stall with the right. So,
we go up, left, down, right, up, right,
down, left, up, left, down,
right, up, right, down, left. Like so.
All right. So, I guarantee that the
first time you try this, something is
going to happen that's going to make it
look kind of messy across the top. And
it's going to look something like this.
Either you're going to wind up with both
of the poi just reaching up and over
like so. or you're gonna wind up in a
place where there's kind of an angle
between them instead of that nice
tabletop feel that we want to see across
the top here. So, why does that happen?
The short answer is that it takes some
nuance and subtlety to move the poi
through the position that we want to
have over top. So for your lead po, what
you want to be thinking here is as that
right hand comes around on the first
part of it, you want to think that
you're already going to be stalling up
here when you reach over to the left and
it's going to be like the poi is
dragging your hand across the top. Yeah.
So you want to kind of have this moment
where the poi turns into like a tractor
and it is pulling the trailer of your
hand overhead in order to get around to
this downstall. That's going to be the
thing that's going to make sure that you
have the po head sticking out to one
side across the top and your hand
sticking to the other side like
so. The other part of this, of course,
is the hand that's trailing. And what
you're going to want to do here is
you're going to want to almost feel like
you're dragging the poi through like mud
or something like that. You're pulling
really hard and it's not quite coming.
Once again, this is going to result in a
position where you have the poi over on
one side and your hand on the other side
going across the top in that nice
horizontal line like so. And one last
piece to this is you might be tempted to
kind of have your left hand anticipate
the movement going over top. Avoid that
temptation. Instead, imagine that like
each of these hands is kind of riveted
in place a little bit and they have
little hooks and without getting hooked,
it can't move up and over. It's almost
like you're kind of like pulling
something uh out of a position that has
been stuck in as you're going up and
over here. So, reaching the left hand
means that the right hand kind of slows
down just a little bit because it has to
pick it up and get it moving. And that
is part of how you're going to manage
the momentum going over top. All right.
So, al together we stall the right up,
bring it overhead with the left, stall
the left up, bring it overhead with the
right, stall the right up, bring it
overhead with the left, stall the left
up, bring it overand with the right. In
every case, you want to slow things down
going across the top and avoid having
the po spin over your hands at all cost.
You want to get that nice tabletop feel
as you go across the top there. And the
only way to do it is to slow things down
as you're going through that
moment. Nice. Awesome. I hope that was
helpful. If you got anything out of this
video, please make sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to help other
people find it and to help my channel
grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. And if you would like to support
the work that I do, here are three
options for how you can do it. Number
one, if you want to get your name in the
credits or access to any of a host of
other awesome rewards, you can go ahead
and sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. I will leave a
link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Or if you
prefer not to sign up for a subscription
and you just want to do a one-off
donation, you can do that via either
PayPal or Venmo. I will go ahead and
include links to both of those down in
the description. I am at Drexfactor on
both platforms. Thank you in advance. As
I mentioned earlier, there are a
bewildering array of variations of
stallchasers out there. Now, uh, I
actually did a couple of YouTube shorts
last month showing off a number of them
that I'll go ahead and link to up on
screen. Thanks so much for watching.
Make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.